Markipier: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Overwatch.
Mark: Now I logged on and apparently this group
got a lot bigger than I thought it was,
so i'm here with Patrick, Static, Tesh, Wade and Garr!
Mark: And we're gonna play some Overwatch,
so say hi guys!
Wade: Hello!
Mark; So don't mind about them, focus all on me,
because I'm obviously the best and
everything's going to be wonderful.
Mark; Actually, I am admittedly not the best,
and I will not set up any expectation for myself,
because I just started playing,
But every moment of my spare time has been dedicated
to playing this game.
Right guys?
Wade: *Exactly!   Gar: Obviously!
Mark: I just want you as one group to mumble in agreement to whatever i say
Everyone; *Mumbles of agreement to mark*
Mark; Gimme a nice mumble!
*mumbles*
Mark; That's not mumbling those are words,
gimme some mumbles!
*more mumbles*
Mark; So when I say, so when I say Roadhog grabbed me,
you all just 'mrr mrr mrrr mrr'.
Group mumbles *mrr mrr mrr mrr*
Oh no! It's High Noon!
**Calls for birds**
Wade: Oh no High Noon the Railway
Mark annoyed; Why aren't we finding a group?
Group Member; Hey!
Mark; YEAH! That's what i thought!
Wade;*All you had to do was whine and complain!*
a mumble of agreement
Mark; Yeah! I'm bringing up the low-level greatness
One of the group members; *I prefer fighting against low levels...*
one of the members; *We're not addicted to this game*
Mark; Well I'm addicted but I'm in the early stages where I still have hope,
You guys, yeah, you guys... you guys are just gone.
Wade; *I haven't seen my Youtube Channel in a month...*
Mark; What does that mean?
Mark; what are you talking about?
Mark; Alright so this one's an escort map,
Mark; we gotta get the thing to the thing
Mark; or whatever.
one of the members; *It's just like Team Fortress 2*
Mark; yeah whatever don't compare it to Team Fortress 2!
Mark; That's what everyone else does!
Wade; Someone at the cliff in the back. Some one shooting the widowmaker,
Group Member: *Oh look we're scaring them, they're all leaving!*
Mark; They should be scared
Wade; *The Widowmaker in the back is not leaving*
Wade; *WHY?!*
Everyone except wade; *Laughter*
Mark shouting ; Mei!
Game voice Athena says Attack.
Mark; I'm going for it!
Mark yells happy; Weeeee!
Belive its wade; *Just watch that Widowmaker*
Mark; I got her!
Mark; I'm knocking her off her terd!
Group member; I found Tracer!
Mark; i thought i was knocking her off her terd...
terdy, terd,ferd..
turtle
jus-nerdn
Group Member; *Oh! They got a sniper!*
Mark; Yes, we know
Mark; We're aware of the sniper, where is she?
Group Member; *I got a Hanzo on the roof*
Mark; Where?
Mark; What are you talking about?
Wade; *There's a Hanzo on the roof*
Mark; There's a dead Hanzo on the roof
Mark; I don't know what happened to her
Mark unwidly; him
Mark; whatever, i can't tell with that boob hanging out
Mark; You never know with these things
Group Member; *Well that's getting cut out*
Mark; No it's not!
Mark; Is's is my video!
Mark; forget you
Mark; Man, that Widowmaker does not want to come out over there
Wade i believe;  *Oww! My sides!*
Mark; What did you do... OW!
Mark; Who's doing that?
Mark; Ahh! There's a frickin' someone behind
Mark; Genji
Mark; Woah, hello
Mark; This Genji is giving me
Mark; Oh...I hit him right in the face apparently
Group member laughts
Wade; *Well I'm out see you guys!*
Mark laughs at wade's death.
Wade; *I was gonna charge them but they died as i charged*
Wade; *so i just ended up leaving*
All except Mark; *Ha ha ha ha*
Group Members; *I've got my High Noon guys...*
*It's High Noon*
Mark; No-one cares about your stupid moves.
Mark; What? How did... There we go, ok
Wade; *Where are you, Mark? Are you flying above us?*
Mark; No! I had to take care of this Widowmaker because she was mean.
*Mine!*
*There you go*
Mark; There's, there's a bunch of them rounding the corner right about now
*Oh there's Mai !*
Mark; Where's Mai?
Group Member; There's a Tracer around here
*Oh God!!*
Almost got the Tracer
*Ahhhg!*
*Cuckaaw!*
Ah shit
Dammit, just missed the Tracer
Got the Tracer
*Don't die!*
Yeah- Oh! Symmetria got knocked over there.
There we go
Ok, so far so good.
Did everyone die? Oh,
*Agreement from group*
Yeah, I didn't see any of that happening
*Oh,*
*I'm sure if I did good you would cut that out*
Ow- they're gonna get me, they're gonna get me
*Ohhh- right in the face!*
Ow! I'm getting froze, yeah
Alright guys, I don't know what the hell
happened there, but I died
Um, I was pretty sure the priority in this video
was to make sure that I live at all times,
and look the best possible
And also each one of you shout out my channel
On your channels-
*laughter from group*
So, there's a lot of that  not happening here
and- um, I'm very disappointed in you guys
*Mark, you have like the best channel, like ever*
*like*
Thank you, but that dosen't get me more subs
It's not about being good
He he he
*So good looking, man, you know...*
That's more like it *chuckles*
Tell me how good at Pharah I am
Sarah I am NOT your justice just rains
from the book from an altered you know
*Your justice just rains from above*
It sure does, doesn't it?
Johnny's mom
where you be hurt broke it up into the
flight Apple they got killed
*Where are you being hit from?*
*The butt*
Ow I got killed
What the hell guys
is it was awesome going behind enemy
lines and you know he's let me I was
*All laugh*
I was off on my own behind enemy lines!
And you guys let me die!
*I feel like thats might be a part of your problem*
like that's might be part of your
problem here
What? WHAT?
Farrah I'm a strong independent woman
who don't need you to tell me what to do
I am Pharah! I'm a strong independent woman who don't need you guys to tell me what to do
Now get out of the way so I can ultimate do steal the show!
now get out of the way so i can ultimate
trigger LOL show
fuck that tracer there is something
Fuck that tracer
Oh
my mom was there no assistance on this
part about the guys grab that we won
*Laughs*
Why - Why was there no assistance on this? Huh?
What the hell guys
*Bahad*
WHAT? I am in the spawn room and we won? You guys need to make me LOOK BETTER!
you guys need to make me look better
believe me we tried there's just no
doing the head
*Laughter*
*Mark belive me, we tried there's no doing that*
haha that play hey I don't know what I
did what did i do you know you were so
HaHA! .. Hahaha!
I don't even know what I did.. what did I do?
*You were so good you got play up the game, look at this...*
good
you got a layup a look at this Phil I
hope that you all
*I hope that's all. Just one kill.*
One Killed justice
*Justice!*
we'll see fuck you look good
*Laughter* See? Fuck you guys, I look good!
and even though i'm not on this main
menu here with all of my other teammates
Even though I'm not on this main menu here with all of my other teammates on here, I'm probably good.
on here i'm probably good
maybe we're gonna save your
commendations don't common date each
Maybe
*Laughter* Everyone save your comendations. Don't commendate each other just wait until I pop up next game.
other just waiting till I pop up next
*I commendated myself because no one else did* *Laughter*
but did it myself because no one else
did I want to say this was a team effort
I-I want to say this was a team effort, but you guys know it wasn't, it was all me.
but you guys know it wasn't it was all
me with various leave I don't think it
With honestly play the game
would have been able to get through that
it wasn't for you as as we wait for the
*I dont think we would be able to get through that if it wasn't for you
as-as we wait for the next game I'm just going to replay my play of the game to my viewers so th-that they can see how good I was
next game i'm just going to replay my
play the game to my viewers so that they
can see how good I was
I was what I was it was the worst play
the game just like the pathetic moments
I wish there wa- I wish there was a worst play of the game
Just like the pathetic moments when I go up into the air,  rain justice, and then die
when I go up in the air
rain justice and then . he just just
wait for the cutter and just tell you my
*Justice where's th- eh~*
Justice wa- uhh
*my favorite tobion highlights dies immediately and you have that little corpse*
favorite told you what I like to win
your eyes and you can I look cool or or
or, or-
*-or just a highlight when he's smacking his turt with a hammer*
just the highlight is just snacking is
literally a hammer to thank you guys
*laughter* Guys don't worry, I'll be pharah.
don't worry I'll be Farrah
ok because i didn't want we gotta roll
down
*gibberish mixed with laughter* *I-I was afraid someone wasn't gonna be*
I was afraid so wasn't gonna be you are
you 16 man Farrah
Yeah, honest *are you a six man pharah?
no no no no helical spring we just have
a good time whenever you hear him say
*mixed "no!"s*
screw you!
*From just time to time, whenever you hear him say "Hey mark, you wanna just-" Just say no* Yeah
hey Mark you want to just say no
yeah I look better if everyone else
looks like me it's not okay
How can I look better if everyone else just looks like me?
it's not okay
*we're going to jail..*
what is Jail it's free . it's like a
prime minister
*we're going to jail?* *laughter*
you did I'm disrespected a well known
you to be like that
you disrespected a well known youtuber
t-that's not allowed.. come on now
that's not allowed to come on now
there's a castle or casablanca but
*laughter*
there's a Guantanamo for bed
I know but I just look good cited by
doing so it brain salad is what happened
you better be careful or else you're
gonna go to Casablanca the other
there's a high noon man died off oh god
kill him
it's like what's causing doing I'm I
mean it's just like that's that's what
he does out monkey
okay monkey who the hell's monk is a
river behind us where he is inside this
is trying to destroy target destroyed my
turn to cook a pickle
he was very successful all is not a bad
fair he's dead Matt Farah
yeah there's some someone's trying to be
me out
I couldn't get him I didn't have them I
had him I lost them
you guys let me get the Crete you may
create yourself to do it you decided to
be it was a sacrifice we're willing to
make
thank you three are brutal off and
welcome honest to say i want to defend
ah no why would we do that got a guy on
the point I was being cool over in the
sides thank you - for sale ice
I was trying to be have been off the off
the . the motor cabin is Kevin monkey on
the road legs oh man
right I'm sorry mark
let me to take that killed which would
be why don't ya i was so close to
getting them
that guy's dead that guy's dead loss not
dead yet but going to be done as an
angry monkey
got ya out there is a monkey
I will get to know Jesus
I tell me tell me someone help me do we
don't have heels
I got it fuck me they're trying to set
up a teleporter symmetrix behind us
double-teamed worsted Pam Anderson
Oh with stop wait stop sup
there's a family-friendly channel come
on where's the help Jeff mind
we don't have a healer and I believe
healers are for losers appears
haha what was that marked the dud
no I with someone else I wouldn't do
that i would not just this course .
record got McCreery radio base
you're far too talented and not be a
beautiful and thank you can go right
attach the metron website stairwell I'm
coming for her
I don't know
not really funky almost dad fucking
finished state fuck well uh huh
we're symetra she's off to the right
side
somehow she survived way to blast where
I don't see your you guys are lying old
shit there she is
well I my food oh my god
ok I thought okay good monkeys angry mr.
monkey
hi monkey got him nice eliminated Kevin
what's a monkey - I think you shouldn't
from thought away
I wait if you can might not tell you
dragged its to dragons do get out
it's a duke it out now
tirado coming up the left side he's
coming from behind intimidates just got
American mistaken
hey yeah we're the greatest we're the
best
I'm the greatest my life yeah okay
wow we got it cheap that was that was
good job guys I was great work
yeah we got pests is its turret were
shooting
yeah trouble together and even if it was
just me tell her
did you drop that you worked very hard
for where the kill
oh did you like them go man
yes you got my vote man i give all votes
oh looks to me like you're layin of
people like so much work that highlight
intro with the group
I'm going to replay my highlight from a
previous of that I played and recorded
over that of the newer just love it
wow way to go mark you different map
different there's different news
no no
operating at maximum efficiency
press the attack
**fart noise**